first dates are very delicate is anyone
on a first date this evening
on your own
well my fir my brother good luck if
you're on a first date to see first
dates are very delicate because if you
call her the next day she'll think
you're too keen she'll be put off
if you never phone should i think the
worst of you so what i do as a
compromise is i phone her the next day
and call her a slag
but it's good to be with somebody
because those dating apps those aren't
fun you know every girl would always ask
me how tall i was you ladies are all a
bunch of filthy height supremacists yeah
you over six feet you over six feet you
over six feet i felt bad i feel like i
had to come up with something i was like
well no but if it helps i'm still
growing as a person
[Laughter]
i'm
single
i was actually dating i was here's
here's what happened
now i i this is you need to pay
attention if you like pornography
um don't act why are you acting like you
don't even know what it is i'm like you
like pornography like
what is this pornography he speaks of
um
i was a big fan of porn so i ended up
dating a porno chick
don't do that
it is not what you think it's going to
be i mean it is
what you think it's going to be like
when it you know comes down to you know
crunch time
but it's not the same like when you
start to actually like the girl because
uh the girl i was dating when we first
started dating only did um girl girl
scenes which was great for me
because you know i'm like hey that's my
that's like the loophole of dating a
porn star you could say my girl does
porn oh yeah but she only does chicks
and then your guy friends were like damn
really
and you're like yeah that's right i'm
that dick that she's getting you know
what i mean and then
she resigned a contract and ended up
having to do dudes
and that's when i broke up with her
because she was like well why why don't
you give it a chance i'm like well
here's the problem
you know when most girls come home from
a hard day at work their feet are
hurting
so i'm single
this happened a long time it was an old
bit but i'd like to get it on film but
it's a i think it's an interesting story
happened years ago had a bad breakup and
i met a girl on a dating app and then
she shows up on the date
even better looking than in person like
incredibly beautiful and we go on a date
in brooklyn and
it was it went pretty well i mean i i
was gonna say we got drunk but it was me
i got drunk
i remember it was a cold new york winter
and i grabbed her and i kissed her and
as i let her go she goes oh my i didn't
expect that so proper and i was so drunk
i just said you better [ __ ] expect it
never heard from her again
and rightfully so until
a few months later she texts me
uh just during the day on a friday
afternoon
how are you i said i'm good she goes i
want to see you when i want to get
freaky with you
and i don't know to respond to that oh
yeah with a question mark i don't i'm
not used to fielding that
and she said where are you i said i'm in
union square and she goes do you want to
get your dick sucked or not
so i excuse myself from lunch with my
parents uh because
this feels like a time-sensitive call
[Laughter]
so i i pick up it doesn't even feel like
it's her i feel like more likely some
dude stole her phone
and this is his plan to rob me he's
going through he's like who's the
dumbest [ __ ] of this guy right here
you want to get blown yes i do meet me
at this warehouse in queens all right
so i call her and she's like look it's
me i've had a bad week at work i want to
see you and i want to have sex with you
is that so bad it's like that's great i
hang up i go back to my parents i said
mom i got to get out of here this
audition just came up
and my mom said yeah i'm not proud of
this moment i'm lying to my mother's
face
in pursuit of oral sex i don't feel good
about myself
and my mom goes go get him sammy and i
was like i hate myself all right so
i'm off i'm going over there
and everything about it reads wrong but
i'm like you know it's new york city
it's it's people do this people sublet
it's a different apartment than when she
dropped me off and i'm like yeah it
makes sense people sublet it's fine uh i
get to the building it feels shady so i
get there it's like a nice doorman
building in brooklyn and i said just
come downstairs have a drink with me
she's like i'll come down but i have
scotch upstairs i'll just meet you in
the lobby she comes she looks beautiful
we go upstairs and everything about this
felt weird there's no furniture
in the apartment there was just a couch
and a bottle of scotch it felt like i
marched onto a porno set
and we start making out and then she
starts going down to me and i'm just i
had killed a couple scotches and as
she's going down to me she just stops
and goes i sure hope my roommate doesn't
catch us
and i said yeah i also hope your
roommate doesn't catch us let's
let's go to your bedroom and she goes no
i want him to catch us
that's when i should have left
unfortunately i was with my penis at the
time and that guy
he's kind of persuasive
i was like we should get out of here my
dick is like let's feel this out for a
second
are you sure penis she's like yeah i got
this
we go to her bedroom she picks up right
where she left off she's going down to
me and then she just stops
and i was like why'd she stop and then
she just kept going and then i turned to
my right
a guy is there he's been there the whole
time i've been shut up he's jacked he's
wearing a tank top he's tatted up for
some reason he's wearing a cast i don't
know why that's stuck in my mind
he's just staring at me while she's
going down to me and the moment of panic
i turn i go can i help you
that's what came out of my mouth can i
help you
sounds very casual can i get you
anything
i was terrified he goes are we going to
do this or what and i said oh i think
there's been
a misunderstanding and you know he
starts walking closer i don't know if
you've ever been terrified with a
direction it's a very confusing feeling
he said are you gonna do this or not and
i said do what he's like her and i said
no i don't
he's like you're either in or you're out
and i was like what is this ocean's 11
i'm [ __ ] not
this is not who i am man it's not me and
he said well the door's that way and i
kind of look at him like one i look at
her and she shrugs i'm so scared i'm
traumatized i'm like what the hell are
they going to rob me i don't even pull
my pants all the way i kind of like pull
them up and i waddle out
i've had friends tell cool orgy stories
i'm like my story ends with me waddling
from my jansport and then running out
the door
pathetic i'm walking around brooklyn
feeling terrible about myself
i'm just like what a loser i am and then
as just as i couldn't feel any lower my
mom calls me
to see how the audition went
and i said mom more people now for the
part that i anticipated and
i think they're going to go with this
other guy
[Music]
oh everybody gives me advice on the best
way to meet that certain someone you
know like my sister emily she always
tells me the best way to meet someone is
to go on the internet
go online you'll meet someone i'm like i
thought it'd be a good idea because my
sister she's cool people she goes to
school she goes to church she's nice but
i got to tell you guys something she's a
freak you know you meet her in person
she's all sweet and innocent oh hello
how are you nice to meet you bye
but you catch her online at two three
o'clock in the morning man she's like
i'm licking and sucking your toes
[Applause]
oh do you like it
now see that's scary it is because i had
no idea she was online i was like yeah i
like it
[Applause]
i was like what's up
i see my sister the next day she's like
i met someone i said me too
check it out i got some sandals what's
up
but you guys have to be careful you have
if you're going to meet people on the
internet be careful because you don't
know what you're going to get you don't
i went on a blind date with a girl who
was half sasquatch
[Applause]
it's like bigfoot only smaller
like cousins you know
you got to be care because if they throw
these little mysterious words out there
to kind of like in you know get you
excited like this one girl she described
herself as
bubbly
you know and i hear bubbly and i was
thinking oh my god
[Applause]
man and instead what i got was
[Music]
and i'm standing there
you have to be careful and i said you
know what i'm you know okay maybe i'm
just it's my bad luck it couldn't
possibly happen to me three times right
so i gave it another shot i went on
another blind date with a girl who said
she was a sexy latina
i was excited what's up
i get to her house you guys she was not
latina oh no
she was black
i didn't have a problem with her being
black but she specifically wrote out i'm
latina so i called her on it right i
said hey girl
um
before we go any further
didn't you say that you were latina you
know what she told me she got mad she
was like fool i am latina shoot that's
my name
[Applause]
all right then
that's cool
i love the tv though anything on the tv
at all watch game shows ever watch him
he was at game show the dating game
that's the oddest game show i ever saw
that show you know they got no prize in
the show they just give you like uh
another contestant that's your prize
just parry off no budget at all in the
show you know and they always do the
same thing on the show they get a
beautiful girl match her up with three
giant geeks there you know
last week they had a guy i was like a
crazy guy loony bin kind of a psycho
wingnut you know
you can tell about how to introduce her
bachelor number two is a shadowy lurking
character
from no fixed address please welcome
he's just a guy
menacing figure shambles into the studio
there you know then they made the girls
you know ask those questions they always
be about sex you know always thinly
disguise sex you know never direct you
know
insertion or anything because always i'm
about you know like a girl go back to
number two if i were a popsicle
what would you do to me
what would you do if you fire a popsicle
that's what it says in the card here
so you guys are if you're a popsicle huh
well first of all i guess i'd uh
take your wrapper off
if you know what i mean
and then i grab ahold of your sticks
if you know what i mean
then i
press you against the counter to your
broken too
but happy in the freezer the later
[Music]
you know what i mean all right